el gobierno británico defendió una vez
más en el parlamento del contenido de
esta nueva ley que según sus palabras
acabará con la inmigración ilegal a
través del Canal de la Mancha que en el
2022 alcanzó un récord con más de 45.000
personas que llegaron al Reino Unido a
través de esta vía y mientras el
gobierno defiende esa política el
partido laborista el más grande en
oposición asegura que esa medida no
acabará con el problema de fondo y es
detener la llegada masiva de pequeñas
embarcaciones a través del Canal de la
Mancha según el actual sistema
migratorio británico quienes arriben por
esta vía no son expulsados o deportados
sino que entran a un sistema en el que
pueden solicitar el asilo mientras esta
solicitudes Son procesadas son alojados
en hoteles y esto cuesta según cifras
entregadas por el mismo gobierno seis
millones de libras esterlinas al día que
son pagadas Entonces por las finanzas
públicas
jefe de laborismo keystalmer dijo que
este sistema de inmigración está roto
porque el solo el 1% de esa solicitudes
de asilo han sido procesadas esa ley que
no ha sido votada todavía en el
parlamento pero que tanta polémica está
causando
propone por ejemplo que quienes lleguen
al Reino Unido a través del Canal de la
Mancha o por otras vías ilegales serán
detenidos y deportados enviados a
terceros países como Ruanda o a sus
propios países de origen y no podrán
volver a solicitar la posibilidad del
asilo en el Reino Unido el Primer
Ministro Richie sunat dijo que esta es
una prioridad para el país pero lo
cierto es que es una prioridad para su
partido el partido conservador de Cara a
las elecciones de 2024 fuera del
parlamento también se han escuchado las
voces de organizaciones de derechos
humanos y organizaciones de Caridad que
han criticado también el contenido de
esta ley por cruel e inhumana